so many people in the limelight don't
speak up about racism about equal pay
and about feminism what drives you to do
it and to get it so well it's important
for me it's always been important for me
to point out and injustice whatever I
see it the more longer I've been in in
this industry the more I've seen and if
you're part of the industry you're part
of the problem so talking about it isn't
enough so it's now important to put that
talk into action and hopefully you know
being in films like Miss Sloan it's a
character that shatters gender
stereotypes of what it is to be
ambitious and over-prepared and that
they don't have to be masculine traits a
woman can be those things and it is
perfectly acceptable I like I like
confusing an audience and having a
character just break out of a stereotype
I'm interviewing you on superhero day
and it felt incredibly appropriate base
in your guy's eyes miss lane and and
also in what you're doing to drive equal
pay and Hollywood and to do that would
be sort of treitz something that drew
you to her as a character absolutely I
mean what really drew me to play
Elizabeth you know in the beginning I
was fascinated by the corruption in the
American political system yes of course
the film deals with gun regulations but
it could it could be anything could be
climate change it could be immigration
but that leads her to really to uncover
the fact that politicians aren't um
protecting the people that's just trying
to keep their seat in office and that
means they're following the campaign
finance money
Elizabeth Sloan is an incredible
character to play she's the most
intelligent person in the room she
ruffled a lot of feathers she's ruthless
and we're not used to seeing female
characters like that and I love that
about her the British equivalent to the
to the nasty woman was the difficult
woman and it's so brilliant to see
somebody like that on screen I guess
that's what I mean about her sort of
feeling like a modern superhero lovely
seeing somebody with those many
characteristics and I also love the fact
that we see her
John Grisham novel in early scenes John
Grisham fans will know what that means
are there any other sort of Easter eggs
that we should be looking out for Oh
Easter egg well I'd be great thing about
this films it's a thriller you don't
know what's going to happen next there's
so many twists and turns so the first
time you see it you're kind of like on
the ride and discovering Elizabeth
Sloane but then the second time you see
it you can actually watch the game that
she's playing behind the scenes so it's
a fascinating character study you know
what you can see scenes you know there's
a scene where she fires someone and you
can see the scene right before that
she's preparing for that moment and
that's a great thing about the character
because it the more you watch it the
more little moments you find we also get
an amazing insight into the world of
lobbying which I found completely
fascinating when you were doing your
research were there any sort of favorite
things that you found out about it
anything that really interested you I
thought I'd rather you know what was
fascinating to me was reading about Jack
Abramoff he's an American lobbyist that
was very successful and did things that
were very illegal any ends up in jail
and he was such a dynamic character but
learning about how he started off with
these campaigning for Reagan and you
know throughout his career what he had
accomplished and he really kind of like
changed the whole game for lobbying I
was just surprised by the money I'm just
shocked by how much money is behind the
scenes in DC and what we could do with
that you know I just slide it such a
waste and also the idea of which now
it's not so shocking because with
everything was coming out of the
election the idea that lobbyists can
hire actors or hire people to go into a
protest and kind of like make the
protest people look crazy by holding up
crazy signs the fact that lobbyists do
that under the you know the covers work
is shocking and devious and fascinating
when I thought we were I thought we were
making a movie that was like fictional
reality but then the election happened
you're like nope this is just reality
well it's one last question I find miss
lane amazingly inspiring
character because she's fictional other
than you aspiring are inspiring us with
everything you're doing in Hollywood at
the moment here inspires you
my grandmother inspires me Gloria
Steinem inspires me Hillary Clinton
inspires me there are so many people
that have sacrificed so much to create
the trails that we walk on today the
things that we take for granted the
suffragettes that inspire me because you
know it used to be a bad thing women
were very afraid to associate themselves
with that title of suffragettes you know
it just met women should have the right
to vote just like some women today are
afraid to associate themselves with the
title of feminist which means equal
rights women's rights are human rights
and so I always try to think of the
women that came before me and show
gratitude and thankfulness because I am
where I am today for the paths that they
have created